an alarming new report highlights the
problem of opioid addiction among health
care professionals the report out today
shows more than 44 million doses of
legally prescribed opioids were stolen
last year now that is an increase of a
hundred and twenty six percent from 2017
doctors and nurses were to blame most of
the time
Errol Barnett spoke to a patient and a
doctor about the impact of so-called
drug diversion
Erol good morning good morning look this
report is by a data firm and based
solely on public information like news
reports and police records so what we're
about to show you is likely just a tip
of the iceberg the report found
nationwide patients are at an increased
risk of being seen by a doctor or nurse
misusing opioids I'm not scared anymore
for three years while practicing in
Tennessee dr. Steven Lloyd was among
health care workers addicted to opioids
and treating patients at the same time
has the same prevalence no matter what
profession you are doctors lawyers
judges politicians it also consumed his
personal life in this image while coach
of his son's little league team dr.
Lloyd was high on opioids I had a lot of
education the weird thing is there's
almost no education on addiction his
dependence began after an attempt to
self medicate for anxiety and depression
what I didn't realize was how quickly
how quickly would escalate going from
the half of a 5 milligram lortab to
within three years about 500 milligrams
of oxycontin a day because that's about
how many pills and about 100 vicodin
Lloyd's long hours high stress and easy
access led to plots to take his patients
drugs
there was no requirements on what
happened to those pills that could go
down the toilet or they could go in my
pocket Lloyd has been clean for 15 years
and now works to help other health care
workers battling addiction
Lauren LaLanne ease life was put at risk
by her health care technician who was
addicted to painkillers
there was jaundice I was very very
fatigued when the Leaney went to the
hospital for kidney surgery in 2009 she
was shocked when Leppard hepatitis C and
a liver infection technician Kristen
Parker infected Malini and at least 18
others by stealing their pain medication
and leaving contaminated syringes for
reuse she's now serving 30 years
in prison a system is broken and someone
who might be addicted to some
painkillers is like a kid in a candy
store now get this the Leaney discovered
during the trial that parker the
technician was previously reported for
diverting drugs at another hospital but
that information is protected by
healthcare privacy laws so patients
would have no clue the Justice
Department has a new opioid addiction
detection unit but that was only
launched in less than a third of the
country Gale Errol thank you good to
have you in the studio